Good morning from both coasts.
Oh, we're recording from both coasts.
Jason's still in New York City.
Oh, Sean, are we going to take a look at the weather first?
Yeah, we're going to get into the news.
In the feel-good piece.
You know, we're going to look at the weather.
Traffic on the threes.
东西海岸的各位早上好。哦，我们是从东西海岸两地录制的。杰森还在纽约市。哦，肖恩，我们先来看看天气吗？对，我们要开始聊新闻了。还有暖心小故事。你知道的，我们要看一下天气。三分钟整有交通播报。
We're going to look at the weather right after this wonderful episode of Smartless.
Let's go.
Welcome.
Good morning, everybody.
Oh, hi, Sean.
Sorry, are you about to launch into something?
No.
Hi.
我们看完《聪明糊涂心》（Smartless）这档精彩的节目后就来看天气。我们开始吧。欢迎。大家早上好。哦，嗨，肖恩。抱歉，你是不是正准备说点什么？没有。嗨。
Like, good morning, everybody.
Remember when Sean used to have a bunch of talking about?
points prepared for the coffee class? I always do. I have them today if you want. Do you really?
Yeah. He always does. Do you have it written down on a piece of paper? I jot it down a couple
things that happened. Does Nick do it? No, I do it. Huh. Just right before we sign on.
Does Scotty ever, ever recommend or suggest, hey, you know what will be fun for you guys talk about
to me? Ever? No, not really, no. All right, so what are the, what are the hot topics today?
Yeah, let's go for a hot topic for show. Well, we would have gone there. So my sister was here, you know.
比如说，大家早上好。还记得肖恩以前为“咖啡课堂”准备了多少谈资吗？我一直都准备着。如果你想听，我今天就带了。真的吗？对。他总是这样。你是写在一张纸上了吗？我随手记下了发生的一些事情。尼克也这样吗？不，是我。哈。就在我们连线之前。斯科蒂有没有、有没有推荐或建议过，嘿，你们知道聊这个大家会觉得很有趣吗？有过吗？不，其实没有，没有。好吧，那今天的热门话题是什么？对，我们来聊一个节目的热门话题吧。嗯，我们本来就要聊到那里的。我姐姐来这儿了，你知道的。
Yeah, the Tracy, listener, the Tracy not only exists, but she had a little stay at Shawnee's house.
Yeah, and Jay, you called and she talked to you and you talked to her.
And you two were spooning, right?
I mean, like...
Spooning in bed.
Yeah, Scotty was out.
Yeah, there's nothing weird about that.
No, you guys were cuddling.
对，特雷西，听众朋友们，特雷西不仅真实存在，而且她还在肖尼家小住了一段时间。对，然后杰，你打电话了，她跟你聊了，你也跟她聊了。你们俩当时在勺子式侧卧拥抱，对吧？我是说……在床上勺子式侧卧拥抱。对，斯科蒂出去了。对，这没什么奇怪的。不，你们就是在搂搂抱抱。
That's fine.
Yeah.
We could use, you know what?
We could use more cuddling in this world.
We could.
And maybe a little less gum.
Yeah.
这没问题。对。没问题。你知道吗，我们可以，我们可以多来点拥抱。我们可以的。也许口香糖少嚼一点。对。
Fuck
Every shot
I know it's hard to remember
Because you know we do these like a week apart
And then you forget a lot in six days
It's difficult
Is there like a nicotine cream
What about if you found like a cream
操。我知道每期节目很难记住所有事，因为你知道我们这节目是一周左右录一期，然后在六天里你会忘掉很多东西，这很难。有没有那种尼古丁乳膏？如果你找到一种乳膏，会怎么样？
You could just put on your shoulders
Or something
Yeah what about
Yeah
Is it like like testosterone cream
Oh yeah
That I've read about
Yeah
你可以直接抹在肩膀上，或者类似的地方。对，抹在……怎么样？这就像是睾酮乳膏吗？哦，对。我听说过这个。对。
I've heard about that too
Oh no
Yeah, oh, yeah, it's not working.
It's not working.
I need to do a few more clicks.
So, Shawnee, hot topic.
So Tracy is here, and we watched the documentary.
You guys got to see this.
我也听说过。哦，不。对，哦，对，这不管用。不管用。我得再点几下。所以，肖尼，热门话题。特雷西来了，我们看了纪录片。你们一定要看看这个。
It's called Trust Me, the False Prophet.
Wait, is this the one about the Mormon?
Yes, somebody told me about it.
Well, no, it's not the Mormon.
It's about the fundamentalist church of Latter-day Saints.
Is that not Mormonism?
Which is an extension of.
It's an offshoot.
片名叫《相信我：虚假先知》（Trust Me: The False Prophet）。等等，这是讲摩门教的那部吗？对，有人跟我提起过。嗯，不，不是摩门教。这是关于耶稣基督后期圣徒教会原教旨主义派的。那不就是摩门教吗？这是其中的一个延伸。这是一个分支。
Oh, I didn't know that.
Oh, yeah.
It's wild.
So Sam Bateman, right?
Yes, that's right.
I thought of you.
Oh, but you did.
Yeah, it's, I don't know.
哦，我不知道。哦，对。太疯狂了。所以是萨姆·巴特曼（Sam Bateman），对吧？对，没错。我想到了你。哦，不过你确实想到了。对，这，我不知道。
Explain yourself, Jason.
Yeah, I don't know if there's a relation there,
but I would guess that there is.
I mean, our family is out of Utah.
So, I mean...
No.
That was probably your first tip, I guess, huh?
Was that what kind of got you going in that direction?
解释一下吧，杰森。对，我不知道这之间有没有亲戚关系，但我猜是有的。我的意思是，我们家族来自犹他州。所以，我的意思是……不对。这大概是你的第一个线索吧，我想？这也就是让你朝那个方向想的原因吗？
I'm not an experienced investigator,
but those are two hot leads, name and location.
Nothing gets past you, dude.
It's unreal.
Name and location.
So how is Sam doing, Jason?
Yeah, I have not spoken to him for years.
No, I have no idea.
我可不是什么经验丰富的调查员，但这可是两个重磅线索：名字和地点。什么都逃不过你的法眼，老兄。太不真实了。名字和地点。那萨姆最近怎么样，杰森？对，我很多年没跟他说话了。不，我完全不知道。
I haven't seen him since the family reunion.
But Amanda did actually just this morning say that she finished it,
and she said it's really worth watching,
that it lands the plane very well.
Yeah, it's sad and fascinating and all those things.
It's crazy.
Well, you know, there's a Bateman that runs through
that great John Crackauer book that I optioned and produced that
自从家族聚会后我就没见过他。不过阿曼达今天早上确实说她看完了，她说真的很值得一看，结尾收尾得非常棒。对，这又悲伤又迷人，诸如此类。太疯狂了。你知道的，那本伟大的约翰·克拉考尔（John Krakauer）的书里也有个叫巴特曼的人物，我买下了版权并制作了……
Under the Banner of Heaven.
Under the Banner of Heaven, thank you.
It's a great read.
If you've never read it, it's a great read.
Yeah, it's really tragic, but there is a Bateman that goes through that,
and I bet he's related.
Did you guys, you made that, right?
We did, yeah.
《天堂下的旗帜》（Under the Banner of Heaven）。《天堂下的旗帜》，谢谢。这是一本极好的书。如果你没读过，这是一本必读之作。对，真的很悲剧，但里面确实有一个叫巴特曼的人物，我敢打赌他和你有亲戚关系。你们，你们制作了这部剧，对吧？是的，我们做了。
Yeah, how was it?
I'm going to watch that.
Andrew Garfield plays a lead in that.
Yeah, how was it?
On FX. Great.
Yeah, be honest.
How was it?
Oh, I got to see that.
对，感觉怎么样？我要去看看。安德鲁·加菲尔德（Andrew Garfield）在里面主演。对，感觉怎么样？在FX电视台播出的。很棒。对，说实话。感觉怎么样？哦，我得去看看。
No, I never saw it.
I do want to see it.
I loved that.
I loved that book.
Yeah, that book is...
That story is insane.
What's it, like, generally in a one sentence?
There's these...
不，我从没看过。我确实想看。我很喜欢那本书。我很喜欢那本书。对，那本书……那个故事太疯狂了。大概是讲什么的，能用一句话概括吗？大概有……
It's about 250 pages, probably.
These brothers kill another brother's child and wife
because they say they got a sign from up above.
Oh, God.
It's not a fun.
It's not a fun...
Wait, based on a true story or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
大概有250页吧。这些兄弟杀害了另一个兄弟的孩子和妻子，因为他们声称收到了来自上天的神谕。天哪。这可不是什么好玩的……这可不是什么好玩的……等等，这是根据真实故事改编的还是……对，对，对。
It's a full true story.
But what's interesting about the structure of the book...
Yeah, every other chapter,
sort of it's telling the linear
birth and progression
of the religion of
Mormonism. And you can see how
well you can make your own decisions
完全是真实故事。但这本书的结构很有意思的地方在于……对，每隔一章，它就会以线性方式讲述摩门教的诞生和宗教发展历程。你可以看出……你可以自己做出判断。
about... But Joseph Smith
coming from upstate New York and all that sort of stuff
and then he sort of breaks that down in his way
but either way wherever you land on it it is a kind of
I thought it was an excellent book. He's God
cracker is something else. Yeah
He's the man. Yeah that... Oh Sean
sorry one more to sorry we go let's get to the next topic
关于……约瑟夫·史密斯（Joseph Smith）来自纽约州北部以及诸如此类的事情，然后他以自己的方式进行了剖析，但无论如何，无论你持什么立场，我都觉得这是一本非常棒的书。克拉考尔这人真有一套。对，他是个人物。对，那……哦，肖恩，对不起，还有一个，对不起，我们接着聊下一个话题。
Sorry.
Sorry, we got hung up.
Sorry, we got hung up on this.
You're watching the doc.
Are you worried that you just can't be,
you just can't be yourself in the moment?
Sure.
No, we can, totally.
抱歉。抱歉，我们纠结了。抱歉，我们在这个上面卡住了。你在看那部纪录片。你是不是担心自己在这个时刻无法做最真实的自己？当然。不，我们完全可以。
By the way, every day.
Was that it?
You were just going to make a recommendation for media?
Yeah, and also I saw,
now that we're talking about documentaries,
Jay, I finally saw the apocalyptic.
Oh, yeah, the AI documentary.
Yeah, yeah.
顺便说一句，每天都这样。就这？你刚才是要推荐一部纪录片吗？对，还有我看到，既然我们在聊纪录片，杰，我终于看了那部关于末日的……哦，对，那部AI纪录片。对，对。
AI doc.
That was wild.
So what do you think?
Are you, are you bullish or pessimistic about AI?
Yeah, no, I can't be pessimistic.
I can't.
I have to believe, just so I can get through every day, that AI and us will work together.
AI纪录片。太疯狂了。那你觉得怎么样？你对AI持看好还是悲观的态度？对，不，我不能悲观。我不能。我不能。为了能过好每一天，我必须相信，AI和我们会共同合作。
And AI is not going to destroy the world.
Yeah, that mankind will do the right thing when presented with an option to use this incredible
technology for good or for bad.
I always believe humanity will win out in the end.
Hey guys, you know.
That is so good.
Speaking of humanity, I tell you what.
I believe.
而且AI不会毁灭世界。对，当面临选择是将这项不可思议的技术用于善途还是恶途时，人类会做出正确的事情。我始终相信人类最终会获胜。嘿，伙计们，你知道的。太棒了。说到人类，我跟你说。我相信。
Wait, Will, are you about to get to the intro?
It's still me.
No, sorry.
Wait, Sean, you had one more bullet point or not?
It was just cultural.
Oh, Sean, we should mention just our little side menu, our little side thing, which is Sean's menu, which is becoming our new.
It's our new, it's our new feature called Sean's menu.
Last night, Jason and I received a text in the chat in a picture of the beginnings of a beginning of a smores extravaganza.
等等，威尔，你这是要进入开场白了吗？还是我。不，抱歉。等等，肖恩，你还有一个重点要说，还是没有？这只是个文化话题。哦，肖恩，我们应该提一下我们的那个小副菜单，我们的那个小栏目，也就是“肖恩的菜单”，这正在成为我们的新……这是我们的新特色，叫做“肖恩的菜单”。昨晚，杰森和我收到了群聊里的一张照片，是一场自制棉花糖夹饼狂欢的序幕。
On a Monday night.
Yeah, I'm not sure it was fully dark out yet, though.
No, not fully dark.
not in a beach setting,
not on a vacation
around a campfire,
just a Monday night in Los Angeles.
Monday night, yeah,
在一个周一晚上。对，不过我不太确定当时天是不是已经全黑了。没有，还没全黑。不是在海滩边，不是在度假时的篝火旁，而只是洛杉矶的一个周一晚上。周一晚上，对。
regular dessert.
It was a...
Desert was at 615, by the way.
Okay, keep going.
And it was elegantly laid out
on a plate with proper ratios
of gram crackers,
chocolate and mushroom,
标准的甜点。这是一个……顺便说一句，甜点是6点15分吃的。好吧，继续。它被优雅地摆在盘子里，全麦饼干、巧克力和蘑菇……
not mushrooms, sorry,
marshmallows.
They're on the plate.
Very dignified.
Like, this is your smores kit
that the chef laid out for you?
No, I did it myself.
I was all alone.
不是蘑菇，抱歉，是棉花糖。它们摆在盘子里。非常讲究。就像这是主厨为你摆盘的棉花糖夹饼套餐吗？不，我自己做的。我当时一个人。
Scotty was out of town.
I was all alone.
I had, so.
That was just for you?
That was just for me, yeah.
And I had four in a row.
But wait, this is the hack.
This is the smores hack.
斯科蒂出城了。我独自一人。我有，所以。那是专门为你自己做的？那完全是为我一个人准备的，对。我一口气吃了四个。但等等，这有个诀窍。这就是棉花糖夹饼的诀窍。
Oh, yeah, tell us.
I take the chocolate and I microwave it,
so it's more like a sauce.
Yeah.
And then I pour the sauce onto the marshmallow.
Oh, you figured it out.
Motherfucker.
Yeah, so it's not like you're just biting into a chocolate.
哦，对，快告诉我们。我把巧克力放进微波炉加热，这样它就更像酱汁了。对。然后我把酱汁倒在棉花糖上。哦，你琢磨出来了。你个王八蛋。对，这样你就不是直接在咬一块硬巧克力了。
Sean, when you just stuff it,
why don't you just stuff it all in your mouth and then hop in a sauna
and just let it milk in your mouth?
Okay.
By the way, that's not a bad idea.
All right.
What are you doing?
Are you making schroes?
肖恩，当你把这些全塞进去的时候，你为什么不直接把它们全塞进嘴里，然后跳进桑拿房，让它们在你的嘴里融化呢？好吧。顺便说一句，这主意不错。好吧。你在干什么？你在做棉花糖夹饼吗？
Most people go in there to lose some weight.
Sean goes in there to really dive into the sweets.
Or to reheat any sort of food.
You'll just walk in there with his plate.
Fucking hell, bang dong.
Unbelievable.
Why waste the wattage?
Well, you were doing that.
大多数人去那儿是为了减肥。肖恩去那儿是为了大肆享用甜食。或者去加热任何食物。他会直接拿着盘子走进去。真他妈的，绝了。难以置信。为什么要浪费电量？嗯，当你在做那个的时候。
I'll say this.
Our guest, Sean, you're going to like this.
He started performing on Broadway at the age of seven.
Really funny.
Okay?
Seven years old starting on Broadway
and has continued on and off on Broadway
amongst the other amazing thing he's done,
我要说的是：我们的嘉宾，肖恩，你会喜欢这个的。他七岁就开始在百老汇表演。非常有趣。对吧？七岁开始在百老汇登台，并且此后断断续续地一直在百老汇演出，除此之外他还做过许多惊人的事情，
which have been,
had multiple number one albums,
chart-topping singles in a group.
And also with a solo career.
Hugh Jackman.
And incredible acting credits across film, TV,
big studio movies, prestige TV,
then returned to Broadway,
比如在组合中推出过多次排名第一的专辑、排行榜冠军单曲。还有他的个人歌手生涯。休·杰克曼（Hugh Jackman）。还有横跨电影、电视、好莱坞大片、高品质剧集的不俗演技履历，之后重返百老汇，
been nominated for Golden Globes,
headlined global tours,
coached on the voice,
okay, and built a career that went from teen idol
to serious actor
and legitimate musician all the way through,
which is howie Mandel.
Okay, he's got his new record came out,
曾获得金球奖提名，领衔全球巡演，担任过《美国好声音》（The Voice）的教练，好吧，他建立了一种从青少年偶像转型为严肃演员和合格音乐人的职业生涯，贯穿始终，他就是豪伊·曼德尔（Howie Mandel）。好吧，他的新唱片刚发行，
February 6th, Sunday Best,
marking his first solo project in nearly five years.
Please welcome to the show.
Nick Jonas, you guys.
Nick!
Come on.
Yeah.
You look nothing like Howie Mandel.
2月6日，《周日精选》（Sunday Best），这是他近五年来首个个人项目。有请今天的嘉宾。尼克·乔纳斯（Nick Jonas），大家欢迎。尼克！来吧。对。你看起来一点也不像豪伊·曼德尔。
Or Hugh Jackman.
Well, give it time.
Give it time.
Hello, Nick.
Good to see you guys.
Nick is seeing you.
This feels overdue.
What an intro.
或者休·杰克曼。好吧，拭目以待吧。拭目以待。你好，尼克。很高兴见到你们。尼克，很高兴见到你。这感觉早该发生了。多棒的开场白啊。
That was great.
Nick, and I just saw you.
It's so insane.
I saw it at the Golden Globes.
I know.
That was so lovely.
We were backstage at the holding room
for the present.
太棒了。尼克，我刚才还看到你了。太疯狂了。我在金球奖上看到过你。我知道。太美妙了。我们在颁奖嘉宾休息室的后台，
my wife was presenting you guys there.
It's not a big room.
That's one of the bleakest, most depressing rooms in Hollywood.
Yeah.
Everybody just walks in and out.
It's way too small.
The ceiling's low.
I did enjoy listening to you guys rehearsed, though.
我妻子当时是颁奖嘉宾。那可不是个大房间。那是好莱坞最荒凉、最压抑的房间之一。对。每个人都在里面进进出出。太小了。天花板很低。不过我确实很享受听你们排练。
It was the master class in Bit.
Well, us three idiots?
And you guys crushed the bit.
It went viral after.
It was great.
Did we honestly rehearse?
You don't remember that.
There's a little side room.
那是玩梗的教科书级别展示。好吧，我们三个笨蛋？你们俩当时把那个梗玩爆了。之后还走红了。太棒了。我们当时真的排练了吗？你不记得了。有个小侧房。
No.
You ran it back like six times.
It was great.
We did?
Yeah.
Just for timing.
And then I'll bet it was nothing like, just for timing.
没有。你们把那个桥段排了大概六次。太棒了。我们排过？对。就为了抓时机。就为了抓时机。然后我敢说这绝对不像是什么“就为了抓时机”。
Just for timing.
You got to do that.
Get familiar with the piece.
Didn't you think that Jason should have spoken up?
He was a little soft on that one line.
If we were still rolling, I'd go back and raise the volume a little bit.
Yeah.
Because you were turned away.
就为了抓时机。你得那么做。熟悉一下那个段落。你不觉得杰森刚才应该开口吗？他在那句台词上表现得有点温吞。如果我们还在拍摄的话，我会回去把音量调高一点。对。因为你当时转过身去了。
The attitude was great and the performance was great.
We just needed to hear it better.
Oh, cheers, man.
You know.
People loved it.
It was great.
I loved it.
Cheers.
态度很棒，表演也很棒。我们只是需要听得更清楚一点。哦，干杯，老兄。你知道的。大家都喜欢。太棒了。干杯。
Nick.
Thanks for having me, guys.
Yes.
Nick.
Of the pod.
Dude, it is.
It's so overdue.
尼克。谢谢你们邀请我来，伙计们。是的。尼克。播客的尼克。老兄，真的是。早就该来了。
It's so overdue that you're here.
And like I said in the intro,
as you go back and you look at all the stuff you've done
from such a young age
and how much incredible success you've not just had,
but continue to have, it's remarkable, man.
It's so singularly, like that is so tough to do.
And it's really a tribute to your talent.
你来到这里真的是早就该发生了。就像我在开场白里说的那样，当你回顾你从很小的时候起所做的一切，以及你不仅取得了多少惊人的成功，而且还在继续取得成功时，这太了不起了，老兄。太独一无二了，要做到这一点太难了。这确实是对你才华的肯定。
It's unbelievable.
It's just that you've always,
at everything you've done, you've excelled,
and you've managed to sort of keep it.
You know, you've done top-rated stuff.
And that, and I wonder if for you,
starting young like that,
did you feel pressure like, I got to keep this going?
这简直难以置信。你在做过的每一件事上都表现优异，而且你设法保持住了这种状态。你知道的，你做过许多收视率极高的作品。我在想，对于你来说，这么小就开始，你会不会感到压力，觉得“我必须把这个保持下去”？
Did you ever feel that pressure starting so young?
I think to a certain degree, yeah.
You know, I started, as you mentioned before,
on Broadway as a kid, was lucky enough to do a few shows.
And then I was actually a family friend that heard it.
A song, oh, is it sound bad?
No, no, family friend, those stories never really go well.
I thought the son.
这么小就开始，你有没有感到过那种压力？我觉得在某种程度上，是的。你知道的，正如你刚才提到的，我小时候在百老汇开始演艺生涯，很幸运能演几部戏。然后其实是有个家族朋友听到了……一首歌曲，哦，这听起来很糟糕吗？不，不，家族朋友，那些故事从来都没什么好结果。我以为是儿子。
I'm on set right now, there's trucks behind me, this little shit.
This one does go well.
Family friend, he also happened to be our chiropractor.
He was like, oh, guys, we're going to take a short break.
He told my dad, he was like, look, you know, I know Nick recorded this song.
I'd love to play it for this guy who works at Sony Music Group.
Did he ask you to just relax?
Thankfully not.
我正在片场，后面有卡车，这个小混蛋。这个故事确实有好结果。家族朋友，他恰好也是我们的脊椎按摩师。他说，哦，伙计们，我们要休息一会儿。他对我爸说，听着，我知道尼克录了这首歌。我很想把它放给一个在索尼音乐集团工作的人听。他有让你放轻松点吗？谢天谢地，没有。
But, you know, started recording
and then we got signed as a trio
me and the brothers.
And I think, you know, because we had sort of
early in our career
had a big failure, our first album did not do well.
We got dropped by our first label.
Oh, go.
但是，你知道的，开始录音，然后我们作为三人组签约了，我和我兄弟们。而且我觉得，因为我们的职业生涯早期遭遇了一次重大失败，我们的第一张专辑反响不佳。我们被第一家唱片公司解约了。哦，天哪。
It took, you know, us finding a home
with Disney and our...
partners there to kind of really step into the next phase.
And I think that resilience came from that early perceived failure.
Right, right, right.
Well, that's, yeah, I mean, did you have, am I right about that?
First of all, I read somewhere that, and I don't know, you tell me if it's true,
that you were first discovered by like a talent manager or a push towards one when you were
我们花了很长时间，才在迪士尼找到了归宿，我们的合作伙伴……并在那里真正迈入了下一个阶段。我觉得这种韧性就源于早期那种感知到的失败。对，对，对。好吧，那是，对，我是说，我有说错吗？首先，我在某处看到过——我不知道，你告诉我这是不是真的——你最早是被一个星探发掘的，或者说当你……
at, like a barber shop, like getting a haircut or something.
I was at a hair salon, my mom, yeah, I was six.
And I was always singing, you know, before.
I was even talking.
And she was getting her hair done.
I grew up in Jersey.
And so we're known for our hair salons,
diners, bowling alleys,
在理发店剪头发还是什么地方的时候，有人把你推向了这一行。我在美发沙龙，我妈，对，我六岁。我以前总是唱歌，你知道的。甚至在我会说话之前就会唱了。她在做头发。我在泽西长大。所以我们那儿以美发沙龙、餐馆、保龄球馆闻名，
and it's about it.
Shop and also.
And, yeah, so she was getting her hair done.
I was singing, the woman next to her said,
hey, my son is Gabrash on Broadway.
I think your son could do it.
She'd go see this talent manager.
So we went in to go see Shirley Grant.
差不多就这样了。还有商店。而且，对，所以她在做头发。我在唱歌，她旁边的那位女士说，嘿，我儿子在百老汇演加夫洛什（Gavroche）。我觉得你儿子也可以。她叫去找这个星探。于是我们就去见雪莉·格兰特（Shirley Grant）。
Was it Gait and Matarazzo by any chance?
Didn't he play Gavroche on Broadway?
No.
He played Gavroch later than,
than I did, I think.
Okay.
I did it in early 2000s.
But basically went into this talent manager's office.
碰巧是盖滕·马塔拉佐（Gaten Matarazzo）吗？不是他在百老汇演过加夫洛什吗？不是。他演加夫洛什比我晚，我想。好吧。我是2000年代初演的。但基本上就是去了那个星探的办公室。
Her name's Shirley Grant, rest of peace, Shirley.
She's got her walls line with, like, you know,
headshots of little actor kids, weird actor kids
who look you in the eye and shake your hand really intense.
He's looking at you, J.B.
He's looking at you.
Did you notice that?
她叫雪莉·格兰特，愿她安息，雪莉。她的墙上贴满了……你知道的，小童星的照片，那些奇怪的小演员照片，他们直视着你的眼睛，非常用力地跟你握手。他正看着你呢，J.B.。他正看着你。你注意到了吗？他在看着你。
And she started sending me on auditions,
and that was kind of the start to my run doing shows.
That's so nuts.
So you played Gavroche and...
I played Gavroche.
Who's Gavroche?
I'm embarrassed to say, I don't know.
He's the kid that basically is the kind of narrator for the second chapter of the story.
然后她开始让我去试镜，这算是开启了我的演艺生涯。太疯狂了。所以你演了加夫洛什，然后……我演了加夫洛什。加夫洛什是谁？我很尴尬地说，我不知道。他基本上是个小孩，算是故事第二章的旁观讲述者。
Basically, when Valjean, have you seen Le Miz?
Of Les Miz.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
He's the only kid in the whole, spoiler alert.
He gets shot in the head and he gets killed.
And as a child actor, it's a, you know, a dream role.
You get to do the old snap of the head back and die.
It's epic.
基本上，当冉阿让——你看过《悲惨世界》吗？我是说《悲惨世界》。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦。他是全剧唯一一个——剧透警告——被枪击中头部然后死掉的小孩。作为一个童星，你知道的，这绝对是个梦想中的角色。你可以表演那种经典的头部后仰然后死去的戏码。这太酷了。
I also played shoot the teacup.
Wait, wait, wait, full sidebar, pause.
Have either, you have, you have, you just admitted.
Have you guys ever been shot in a production,
in a show or anything that you've had to get shot?
No.
Yeah, I think I've bored you guys
with my little house in the prairie story
基本上，当瓦尔让——你看过《悲惨世界》吗？《悲惨世界》。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦。他是整部戏里唯一的小孩，剧透警告。他头部中枪身亡了。作为一个儿童演员，这是一个……你知道的，梦想中的角色。你可以表演那种老式的头部后仰然后死去的戏码。太史诗了。我还演过……等等，等等，等等，完全题外话，暂停。你们俩，你，你，你刚才承认了。你们有没有在任何制作中、演出中或其他什么里中过枪？必须演中枪？没有。对，我想我可能用我的“草原小屋”（Little House on the Prairie）中枪的故事烦过你们了。我第一次中枪……不，不，我从来没听说过。我当时10岁，10岁或11岁，差不多吧。天哪，他们在这些制作里让好多小孩中枪啊。好吧，继续。天哪。
of getting shot.
First time I ever had shot.
No, no, I've never heard it.
I was 10, 10 or 11, something like that.
God, they're shooting a lot of kids.
in these productions.
Okay, keep going.
Jesus Christ.
被枪击。我第一次听到枪声。不，不，我从来没听说过。我当时10岁，10岁或11岁，诸如此类的。天哪，这些制作里有好多小孩中枪。好吧，继续。天哪。
First big gig.
I'm playing this kid.
Me and my older brother, we walk into a bank there in the little western town,
and it's in the middle of getting robbed.
But we don't know that.
We walk in, ding, ding, the door chime goes,
and the bank robbers turn around and see these two those kids,
and he fires and hits me right in the chest or the leg or whatever the hell it is.
第一份大工作。我演一个小男孩。我和我哥哥走进西部小镇的一家银行，当时银行正在被抢劫。但我们不知道。我们走进去，叮咚，门铃响了，劫匪转过身看到这两个小孩，他开枪击中了我的胸部还是腿部，管他妈的哪里呢。
we shoot the rehearsal
Michael Landon's directing this episode
we shoot the rehearsal so
I get shot and I throw myself
against the wall
I slide down the wall
and when I get to the floor
I start shaking and quivering
我们拍排练戏，迈克尔·兰登（Michael Landon）导演这一集，我们拍排练，所以我中枪了，我把自己摔向墙壁，顺着墙壁滑下来，当我滑到地板上时，我开始发抖和抽搐，
like one does
because all you can see
is in the movies and a TV
and then I slowly expire
and all I hear is total silence
my eyes are closed on the floor
and I just hear Michael Landon go
okay we're going to cut and he walks slowly over to me i still have my eyes closed i'm still in and
就像人们中枪那样，因为你所能看到的只有电影和电视里的画面，然后我慢慢断气，我听到的只有一片死寂，我闭着眼睛躺在地板上，我听到迈克尔·兰登说“好，我们切掉”，他慢慢朝我走来，我依然闭着眼睛，我还沉浸在角色里，
he whispers me and he says okay we're going to do another one and this time i'm going to want you to
just collapse on the floor okay next time you get shot i want you to just slowly just collapse
and quietly expired here we go everybody back to walk i was so mortified and embarrassed i mean i was
just you know vibrating and and throwing myself sure
Sure.
Oh, God bless you, Jaby.
That's good.
他对我耳语说：“好了，我们再拍一次，这次我希望你直接倒在地板上，好吗？下次你中枪的时候，我希望你慢慢地倒下，安静地断气，来吧各位，回到起点。”我当时羞愧难当、尴尬至极——我的意思是，我刚才还在那儿浑身颤抖、把自个儿往墙上撞呢。当然。当然。当然。哦，上帝保佑你，J.B.。这太精彩了。
I know.
You're feeling it.
So you do...
So you were going to say,
after Gabriott, you played...
Oh, yeah.
So I did...
My first show, I did a Christmas Carol,
我知道。你感同身受。所以你做……所以你想说，在演了加夫洛什之后，你演了……哦，对。所以我演了……我的第一部戏是《圣诞颂歌》（A Christmas Carol），
which is kind of a seasonal show.
So technically not a Broadway show.
But Annie Get Your Gone was my first show
with Reba, MacGitare.
I did it with Franklangella.
Actually, it was pretty incredible.
Oh, whoa.
He played Scrooge.
这算是一部季节性剧目。所以严格来说不算百老汇演出。但《安妮拿枪》（Annie Get Your Gun）是我跟里巴·麦肯泰尔（Reba McEntire）合作的第一部戏。我和弗兰克·兰格拉（Frank Langella）一起演的。其实真的很不可思议。哦，哇。他演的是斯克鲁奇（Scrooge）。
I was...
Actual character name, Scrooge at 8.
and I was the understudy for Tiny Tim
and in the eight years that this show had run
that they'd never had a Tiny Tim cover have to go on
so they just didn't bother rehearse the Tiny Tim covers
and the year I did it
again my dad gets a call and they say hey
我是……实际角色的名字，8岁的斯克鲁奇。我是小蒂姆（Tiny Tim）的替补演员，在这部剧上演的八年里，他们从来没有让小蒂姆的替补上场过，所以他们根本懒得排练小蒂姆的替补，而就在我演的那一年，我爸接到一个电话，他们说，嘿，
Nick's going to go on for Tiny Tim today
we got to get you here an hour before the show to do a put-in
so I rush over to the theater
and basically run the five scenes
that Tiny Tim has in the two songs.
And, you know, thrown out there for the opening kind of song,
and literally my mind goes blank.
16 bars of just silence as the music's playing.
尼克今天将代替小蒂姆上场，你们得在开演前一小时赶到这儿来做个串场排练。所以我冲向剧院，基本上把小蒂姆在两首歌里的五场戏过了一遍。然后，你知道的，开场的那首歌就把我扔上去了，字面意义上，我的脑子一片空白。音乐响着，整整16个小节一片寂静。
There's really intimidating conductors there, look me in the eye.
It was a good entryway into live theater.
You know, shit happens.
You could just go to roll with it.
But as an 8-year-old, I was pretty mortified.
Scrooge at 8 would be a good title for autobiography
if you ever decided to write one.
I'm going to write that down, actually.
那边有非常吓人的乐队指挥，直盯着我的眼睛。这倒是不错的切入现场戏剧的方式。你知道的，破事总会发生。你只能硬着头皮上。但作为一个8岁的孩子，我当时尴尬极了。如果你以后决定写自传的话，“8岁的斯克鲁奇”会是个不错书名。我得把它记下来，说真的。
That's a good idea.
Wait, did that instill a fear in you about performing going forward?
Well, the conductor came up to me after,
and I was expecting him to sort of scold me or something like a teacher would.
Instead, he came down on my level, and he said, things happen.
You just got to keep going next time.
He said, we're just going to drop to the floor.
Yeah.
这主意不错。等等，这有没有让你对之后的表演产生恐惧？嗯，指挥后来走到我面前，我以为他会像老师那样训斥我一番。相反，他放低姿态对我说，这种事时有发生。下次继续努力就行了。他说，我们只要直接倒在地上就行了。对。
We're just collapsed.
We're not to reset and we need you.
And expire.
And yet you're going to collapse and expire.
Actually, I wonder if, hearing you say that, and Sean, your question,
I wonder if it had the opposite effect.
If having that, you kind of mentioned, like, your first record
wasn't the hit that it didn't go well,
我们只要倒下就行了。我们不用重新调整，我们需要你。然后断气。然而你还是要倒下并断气。其实我在想，听你这么说，再加上肖恩你的问题，我在想这会不会起到了相反的效果。如果你有了那样的经历——你刚才提到，比如你的第一张专辑没大火，销量不好，
that you had that experience at 8 on Broadway.
In a lot of ways, it probably galvanizes you.
Because if you can kind of get through that at such a young age.
Yeah, yeah.
Right?
In a lot of ways, you kind of go like, well, fuck, I've done that already.
Like, you know, otherwise you're waiting for that moment your whole life.
Like, when is going to be the time that I'm going to completely bottle it in the moment, you know?
而你8岁时在百老汇就有过那种经历。在许多方面，这可能反而激励了你。因为如果你能在那么小的年纪经历并挺过那种事。对，对。对吧？从很多方面来说，你都会想，好吧，操，我都已经经历过那种事了。你知道的，否则你一辈子都在等待那个时刻。心想：什么时候会是我在关键时刻彻底砸锅的时候呢？
Yeah, and I've had a few of those two later on.
Sure, sure.
Moments that certainly didn't go the way I hoped.
But, yeah, I do think that those early experiences helped kind of create a foundation that led to me not losing it.
Yeah.
What about the things that went way better than you thought they were going to go at a,
at an early age.
Like, for instance,
对，我后来也经历过几次这样的事。当然，当然。那些确实没有按我预期发展的时刻。但是，对，我确实认为那些早期的经历有助于建立一个基础，让我不至于崩溃。对。那些在年少时比你预期要顺利得多事情呢？比如，
you know,
the,
like the incredible fandom of like,
all of these like girls screaming at you,
even at an age where you might like,
you're just starting to like get all crazy about girls.
And like has,
is that sort of thing,
你知道的，比如那种不可思议的狂热追星现象，所有的女孩都对你尖叫，甚至在你刚开始对女孩疯狂心动的年纪。而且，就像这种事情，
now that you're,
you're an adult and you have,
you've managed to weather the transition between sort of like teen idol
into,
into an adult, you know, a professional actor, performer, etc.
You know, how does all that stuff kind of transition for you in your head about, you know,
how much of it is real, how much of it is just part of the job,
what do you do with all that sort of like that ego surplus and, you know,
现在你已经是成年人了，你已经成功度过了从青少年偶像到成年专业演员、表演者等的转型期。你知道，所有这些事情在你的脑海中是如何转变的？关于其中有多少是真的，多少只是工作的一部分，你如何处理那些过剩的自我意识，
because it's all kind of junk food to a certain extent.
And like you've got to figure out where to place it all, right?
Yeah, it's a great question.
I mean, I always think it's funny when people frame an answer this way, so forgive me for doing it.
But I think, you know, one of the biggest misconceptions about us and odd to acknowledge your own preconception.
Sure.
But it was that because we worked with Disney and the core of our demo was, you know, primarily teens, that there's no way this music came from an honest source or that it came from us even.
Right, right, right.
因为从某种程度上讲，这些都是垃圾食品。你得弄清楚把它们都放在哪里，对吧？对，这是个好问题。我的意思是，每当有人用这种方式来组织回答时，我总是觉得很好笑，所以请原谅我也这么做。但我认为，你知道的，关于我们最大的误解之一——虽然承认你自己的先入为主有点奇怪。当然。但那就是，因为我们和迪士尼合作，我们的核心受众主要是青少年，所以这种音乐绝不可能是发自内心的，甚至都不是我们自己写的。对，对，对。
And it was a really bizarre thing to sort of be in a spot where at 13, 14 years old,
I was experiencing all the things you're talking about.
First love, first heartbreak, real big human emotions that I was able to put into song
in a way that spoke directly to that audience.
And when you ask about what's something I thought went incredibly right,
it would be that.
The fact that our dad raised us on this great bed of classic.
we discovered our own kind of sound and found our own voice creatively.
处于那种处境是一件非常离奇的事情。在我13、14岁的时候，我正在经历你所说的所有这些事情。初恋、初次心碎、真正巨大的人类情感，我能够把这些融入歌曲中，以一种直接触动那群观众的方式表达出来。当问到有什么事情是我觉得进展得难以置信的顺利时，那就是这个了。事实上，我们的父亲用这些伟大的经典音乐抚育我们，我们找到了自己的声音，并在创作中找到了自己的声音。
And I had this outlet that both helps me process these big feelings,
but also connected in a way that frankly now,
we play these songs 20 years later,
as men and dads and husbands in our 30s,
it's even more resonant with the audience because they've grown with us.
And tracking that over time has just been the most fascinating thing
and pretty special.
to be out, you know.
我有了这样一个宣泄口，它既能帮我处理这些巨大的情感，又能以某种方式建立连接——坦白说，现在，20年过去了，我们作为三十多岁的成年人、父亲和丈夫再次演唱这些歌曲时，它与观众产生了更强的共鸣，因为他们和我们一起长大了。随着时间的推移，追踪这一切实在是太迷人了，而且非常特别，能走到今天这一步。
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
You mentioned that in your dad raising on those classics and musically.
So what was that?
Who is the person, did they discover that, oh, that you had a talent for music, that
kind of came from you or your parents, were they musical in that way?
Like, was that something that they came from them?
Yeah, our dad was a really gifted musician.
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。你提到你的父亲用这些经典音乐抚育你，在音乐上也是如此。那是怎样的？是谁发觉了……哦，你有着音乐天赋，这究竟是源于你自己还是你的父母，他们在这方面很有音乐细胞吗？这可以说是遗传自他们吗？对，我爸爸是个非常有天赋的音乐家。
He's a pianist, a vocalist, and he was actually a pastor when we first started.
We lived in Dallas for a bit where I was born, and we moved to Jersey.
He became a senior pastor at this church there, and music was always a part of our life.
And I think my latest album, Sunday Best, came out in February, really kind of musically speaking, not so much, but lyrically,
but musically touches on some of those early musical roots in the church.
But the thing is that he also really educated us on everything else,
the Bejys, the Beatles, Stevie Wonder, Carol King, all the greats.
And we had a real sort of deep-dive musical education
他会弹钢琴、唱歌，我们刚开始的时候他其实是个牧师。我们在达拉斯住过一段时间，我就是在那儿出生的，后来我们搬到了泽西。他成了那里一家教堂的主任牧师，音乐一直是我们生活的一部分。我想我的最新专辑《周日精选》是在二月发行的，从音乐层面上讲——倒不是说完全如此，但从歌词上，尤其是音乐上，确实触及了我们在教堂里的那些早期音乐根基。但问题是，他也确实让我们在其他所有方面都大开眼界，比吉斯（Bee Gees）、披头士（The Beatles）、史提夫·旺达（Stevie Wonder）、卡洛尔·金（Carole King），所有伟大的音乐人。我们确实接受了非常深入的音乐教育，
by way of those hour-long drives from our house in Wyckoff, New Jersey,
to the city to go perform and shows there.
Eventually, we left the church or were sort of,
pushed out because our music wasn't Christian music, right?
And so some of the people in leadership there were upset about that
and thought that we were sinning.
Sure.
We took a different path.
就通过从我们位于新泽西州威科夫（Wyckoff）的家到市区去表演的那一个小时的车程。最终我们离开了教堂，或者说……被赶出来了，因为我们的音乐不是基督教音乐，对吧？所以那里的部分领导层对此很不高兴，认为我们在犯罪。当然。我们走了不同的路。
Yeah, exactly.
He was looking at you, Sean.
He was looking at you.
Yeah, no, I got it.
Sean, you want to talk about the time that you wake off in New Jersey?
Okay, so listen.
Listen.
To start, yeah.
对，没错。他正看着你呢，肖恩。他正看着你。对，不，我懂。肖恩，你想聊聊你在新泽西州威科夫的经历吗？好吧，听着。听着。首先，对。
But that's, so you had all this music, and then you start,
and then you start acting,
and you have consistently gone back
and seamlessly back and forth
between the two
and sometimes the marriage of the two
in musical on Broadway
and then
但那是，所以你有了所有的音乐，然后你开始，接着你开始演戏，并且你一直在两者之间无缝地来回切换，有时还将两者结合在一起——出演百老汇音乐剧，然后
and then doing serious acting roles
and doing all that stuff
and is there one
I mean you don't have a lane
you have you're occupying multiple lanes
at the same time
and how do you approach it
do you have like an approach like well now
又去演严肃的戏剧角色，做所有这些事情，有没有哪一个——我是说，你没有被局限在一条赛道上，你同时占据了多条赛道，你是怎么看待这一点的？你有没有一种方法，比如“现在
this year I want to spend more time making music
or do it or does it just kind of
of flow. It just kind of flows
and as of course you all know
that the lead time for a film or TV project
is so much longer than
the turnaround time we can have
in music. I could record a song
今年我想花更多时间做音乐”，或者它只是顺其自然？它就是顺其自然。当然，正如你们所有人所知，电影或电视项目的筹备周期比我们在音乐上能够实现的速度要长得多。我可以记录一首歌
this afternoon and then if I wanted to
put it out this evening
but there's so many people
to have to weigh into how
something gets made
on the film and TV side
which is something that is sort of new for me
on the development side of things
在今天下午，如果我想的话今晚就能把它发出去，但在电影和电视方面，要决定一个东西如何制作，需要太多人发表意见了，这对我来说在开发方面还是个新事物，
and I always love hearing and you guys
talk about your process with development and, you know, kind of what that's been like.
Because the last, I'd say six years kind of during and post-COVID, outside of touring and music
and all that, that's been a really exciting thing, is to sort of do my best to forge a path
where I'm a little bit more in the driver's seat than I've been in the past.
Yeah.
I've been really fortunate to be a part of some great projects.
But when you can start to develop things that you feel like are the right next steps for you
我总是很喜欢听你们谈论你们在开发方面的流程，你知道的，那是什么感觉。因为过去，我可以说在疫情期间以及之后的大约六年里，除了巡演、音乐和所有这些之外，这是一件非常令人兴奋的事情，那就是尽我最大努力开辟一条道路，让我比过去更能掌握方向盘。对。我很幸运能参与一些伟大的项目。但当你开始开发那些你觉得是你的下一步正确选择的东西时，
and you're more in a sort of position to make decisions.
It's a really empowering thing.
How are you finding your, like, just to sort of follow up further on Will's question there,
like, are you, what do you find is drawing you more towards acting at times
and what's putting you more in a music mood?
Is it, you know, is it, I don't know, like, I don't know, like.
Yeah, well, I mean, but right, there are certain.
I guess the question behind it all is what is the difference in creative fulfillment that you find between acting and music?
并且你处于更能做决定的位置时。这真是一件赋予你力量的事情。你如何看待你的——为了顺着威尔的问题继续追问下去——比如，你觉得是什么在某些时候把你吸引向表演，又是什么让你进入音乐状态？是，你知道的，是，我不知道，就像……好吧，我的意思是，但是，对，确实有某些。我想这背后的问题是，你在表演和音乐中发现的创造性满足感有什么区别？
You know, what is what's touching you, you know, in your most core place versus some other place?
I don't know.
Yeah, I think that honestly becoming a father, we have a four-year-old, that really changed everything for me as.
as a creative, both on the music side end and as an actor.
And I've always loved acting.
And I've kind of bounced between, you know, things like, you know, Jumanji, for instance,
which is very big and fun and exciting and incredible cast.
And then smaller things, you know, the $1 million movie, right?
你知道的，是什么在触动你，你知道的，在你最核心的地方，而不是其他地方？我不知道。对，我觉得老实说，成为父亲——我们有一个四岁的孩子——这真的改变了我作为……作为一个创作者的一切，无论是在音乐创作还是作为演员方面。我一直都很热爱表演。我曾在各种类型之间跳跃，比如，你知道的，比如《勇敢者游戏》（Jumanji），那非常宏大、有趣、令人兴奋，而且演员阵容不可思议。然后是一些小项目，你知道的，百万美元的独立电影，对吧？
The thing that you just kind of grind and I love both and think that,
that it's amazing to kind of have that range.
And on the music side, you know, the driver is the fans, truly.
And I'm not just saying that.
It's bizarre to get to do anything for as long as we've now been fortunate enough to do,
especially with the way it kind of began, you know, with there is a reality to the fact that teen fans
or that sort of heartthrob label can be a challenging thing to step out of.
And I think our daughter and the experience that I'm having with her
那种你必须付出艰苦努力的项目，两者我都喜欢，而且觉得拥有这种跨度真是太棒了。而在音乐方面，动力其实就是粉丝，真的。我可不是随口说说。能做任何事情长达我们现在有幸坚持的这么久，尤其是考虑到这一切开始的方式，你知道的，事实上，青少年粉丝或那种万人迷的标签确实是一个很难摆脱的挑战。我觉得我们的女儿以及我和她在一起的经历，
have me way more connected to the words I'm saying,
no matter what they are and kind of my worldview and everything else.
So I can't really say one thing is more inspiring or exciting,
but actually looking at the world through her eyes in a sense
gives me just a better perspective and a deeper, you know,
sort of angle on what I want to be doing.
Well, and you've also had the, you know,
part of your experience has been a big part of it,
让我与我所说的话——无论它们是什么——以及我的世界观和一切都有了更紧密的联系。所以我真的不能说哪一件事更有启发性或更令人兴奋，但实际上透过她的眼睛看世界，在某种程度上给了我更好的视角，以及对我想要做的事情更深刻的、你知道的理解。嗯，而且你也有过——你知道的，你的部分经历中很大一部分，
on and off, has been continued to work with family, right?
To work with your brothers on and off.
I mean, that's also very unique.
And in addition to your solo work as a musician,
and then your solo work, if you will, as an actor
going from project to project, one of the sort of the,
one of the through lines has been,
has been,
断断续续地，就是继续和家人一起工作，对吧？断断续续地和你的兄弟们一起工作。我的意思是，这也是非常独特的。除了你作为音乐人的个人作品，以及你作为演员在不同项目之间转换的“个人作品”（如果你这么叫的话）之外，贯穿始终的主线之一就是，
uh,
what you've created with,
with your brothers.
And I wonder,
is that something that you like,
is that something that feels good as,
as a sort of a steady thing that's always there that you can kind of lean on that,
that,
你和你的兄弟们共同创造的东西。我在想，那是你喜欢的东西吗？那是一种感觉很好的稳定事物吗？它一直都在，你可以依靠它，
that idea of that family and you guys doing that stuff together.
What's that experience like?
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's,
um, it's incredible to do,
那种家庭的概念以及你们一起做那些事的感觉。那种体验是什么样的？对。这……这……和自己爱的人一起做任何事情，
you know,
anything with,
with,
with the people you love and,
and,
简直太不可思议了……
And, you know, we also had a moment where it wasn't good.
You know, we've had that chapter of the journey, too,
where we had to basically say,
let's not do the music together anymore or work together
so that the family at, you know, at the table
can still all be there and love each other.
And, you know, I think it took us sort of going through that season
而且，你知道的，我们也经历过关系不好的时期。你知道的，我们也有过那段旅程中的篇章，当时我们不得不基本上说：我们不要再一起做音乐了，或者不要再一起工作了，这样我们在饭桌上的家庭关系才能维持下去，大家才能依然彼此相爱。你知道的，我想我们经历那个时期，
and coming out the other side in a healthy way.
Yeah, because you guys.
went through like a you know the period in everyone's life of change that happens between the ages of like 15 and 20 is massive you know like
that was the you guys were just tied at the hip during those those years yes or i mean what yeah absolutely um
it was uh you know it was both good and bad there are times you i look up and i look at folks who who
went through similar experiences to us who were on sort of a solo journey
and didn't have that built-in support system.
Because we would check each other too,
并以健康的方式从另一端走出来，真的很难得。因为你们经历过……你知道的，每个人在15到20岁之间都会经历巨大的转变期，你知道的，你们在那些年里简直形影不离。是的，我的意思是，真的吗？绝对是的……这……你知道的，既有好有坏。有时我抬头看着那些经历过与我们类似经历、独自前行并且没有这种内置支持系统的人。因为我们也会互相监督，
which was important to the dynamic and also be a shoulder to lean on
when there was tough times and frustrating situations to navigate.
Yeah, I mean, you want to change so much, right?
During those years, you kind of like you try on these little outfits.
I mean, Willie, we're seeing it with our kids, right?
During those ages, like, you're kind of like,
you're kind of flexing a little bit.
seeing kind of like what kind of young adult you want to become.
这对这种动态关系非常重要，而且在遇到困难时期和令人沮丧的局面需要应对时，也能成为一个可以依靠的肩膀。对，我的意思是，你太想改变了，对吧？在那些年里，你有点像在尝试不同的风格。我的意思是，威利，我们在我们孩子身上也看到了，对吧？在那些年纪里，你有点像在……你有点像在展示自己，
And if you've constantly got a sibling there,
that's why siblings fight so much is that you're always calling each other bullshit,
you know, and like, oh, stop with the face or with, oh, nice, nice outfit,
or what's going on with your hair, you know?
I was thinking about this with us, like as you were saying it,
and obviously it's very different, but the three of us, Nick, in this way, have been.
You're like brothers.
Yeah, we've been friends for a long time.
And if you've constantly got a sibling there, that's why siblings fight so much is that you're always calling each other bullshit, you know, and like, oh, stop with the face or with, oh, nice, nice outfit, or what's going on with your hair, you know? I was thinking about this with us, like as you were saying it, and obviously it's very different, but the three of us, Nick, in this way, have been. You're like brothers. Yeah, we've been friends for a long time.
We're settled into who we're going to be.
Yes, but at the same.
same time we check each other all the time i face time with both of you yesterday uh i was going to do
this thing on thursday and jason's like you got to play golf me i'm leaving i'm going to new york
you have to move that thing because i'm leaving i'm not going to be able to play for a while i was
like okay and i called the guy i was going to do with i go i have to go because jason's leaving
and i have to play a golf with him the day before he leaves and he goes i think it's so sweet that
you guys still want to hang out with each other and i didn't even occurred to me yeah but i get it like
We're settled into who we're going to be. Yes, but at the same. same time we check each other all the time i face time with both of you yesterday uh i was going to do this thing on thursday and jason's like you got to play golf me i'm leaving i'm going to new york you have to move that thing because i'm leaving i'm not going to be able to play for a while i was like okay and i called the guy i was going to do with i go i have to go because jason's leaving and i have to play a golf with him the day before he leaves and he goes i think it's so sweet that you guys still want to hang out with each other and i didn't even occurred to me yeah but i get it like
you guys are my constant in that way.
Like you're my thing,
we come back and get to do this together in that same way.
And we,
so I can kind of relate to that.
It's different.
Again, I'm not...
And you also, you guys are probably as fiercely protective as we are
you guys are my constant in that way. Like you're my thing, we come back and get to do this together in that same way. And we, so I can kind of relate to that. It's different. Again, I'm not... And you also, you guys are probably as fiercely protective as we are
about maintaining the harmony,
because it does take some diligence.
We don't talk to each other about, like,
you know, the effort I made to avoid a conflict with you.
Like, no, you've got to take care of that shit internally
and make sure that you're being the...
right partner to keeping everything.
Like any family.
about maintaining the harmony, because it does take some diligence. We don't talk to each other about, like, you know, the effort I made to avoid a conflict with you. Like, no, you've got to take care of that shit internally and make sure that you're being the... right partner to keeping everything. Like any family.
Yeah, like any family, any relationship, you got to do your part.
Yeah.
And you got to also talk a decent amount of shit to the people you love.
You have to.
Which you guys have in spades.
You have to, you.
Wait, Nick, is there anything, as far as your music goes,
I was thinking about this when Will was kind of touching on this too.
Yeah, like any family, any relationship, you got to do your part. Yeah. And you got to also talk a decent amount of shit to the people you love. You have to. Which you guys have in spades. You have to, you. Wait, Nick, is there anything, as far as your music goes, I was thinking about this when Will was kind of touching on this too.
And you were speaking about it.
Is there anything, how do you determine of your personal life what to share?
in a public forum through art.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, it's a good question.
There are things that I...
Thank you.
That I...
And you were speaking about it. Is there anything, how do you determine of your personal life what to share? in a public forum through art. You know what I mean? Yeah, it's a good question. There are things that I... Thank you. That I...
Even a stop clock tells the right time.
Yeah, no, he's got nominations, so back it up.
Yeah, he sure does.
Interviewer of the year.
Yeah, I don't think...
Did he win?
He did not win.
Did not win.
Even a stop clock tells the right time. Yeah, no, he's got nominations, so back it up. Yeah, he sure does. Interviewer of the year. Yeah, I don't think... Did he win? He did not win. Did not win.
He did not win that one.
No, he did not win.
He didn't win until it got to the co-host version of the nomination.
And then we won.
Congrats.
There are things that I feel, you know, are probably better to just keep private, you know,
or find a different way to say it.
But I have lived a lot of my life, you know, in the public eye.
He did not win that one. No, he did not win. He didn't win until it got to the co-host version of the nomination. And then we won. Congrats. There are things that I feel, you know, are probably better to just keep private, you know, or find a different way to say it. But I have lived a lot of my life, you know, in the public eye.
Right.
Yeah, no shit.
It would be odd to not acknowledge some of the things that are already known about it.
Right.
So you write these lyrics.
You know that you, I mean,
a writer only writes what a writer knows. So I'm assuming that your feelings, your emotions,
your stories come from your life experience. And then oftentimes you want to sort of explore
Right. Yeah, no shit. It would be odd to not acknowledge some of the things that are already known about it. Right. So you write these lyrics. You know that you, I mean, a writer only writes what a writer knows. So I'm assuming that your feelings, your emotions, your stories come from your life experience. And then oftentimes you want to sort of explore
this through a song, but you're afraid the public might sniff out who that person might be.
So you kind of change a name, maybe even change a gender, change who you are, change the,
or make it a metaphor, right? Like all of a sudden it's about two dogs in a park or whatever.
Like,
what an imagination.
Yeah, thank you, man.
So is there a little bit of like a concoction going there sometimes when you're,
when you're writing out lyrics?
this through a song, but you're afraid the public might sniff out who that person might be. So you kind of change a name, maybe even change a gender, change who you are, change the, or make it a metaphor, right? Like all of a sudden it's about two dogs in a park or whatever. Like, what an imagination. Yeah, thank you, man. So is there a little bit of like a concoction going there sometimes when you're, when you're writing out lyrics?
There is, yeah.
And, you know, are you ever a puppy?
Oh, my God, dude.
Enough with the dogs in the park.
Hey, Nick, ever a puppy or a kitty.
That's actually what the entire next album is about.
Fucking, Nick, please write a song about two dogs in a park.
I honestly got it out.
There is, yeah. And, you know, are you ever a puppy? Oh, my God, dude. Enough with the dogs in the park. Hey, Nick, ever a puppy or a kitty. That's actually what the entire next album is about. Fucking, Nick, please write a song about two dogs in a park. I honestly got it out.
There's got to be a way.
And then look over there.
I'll turn it to you first.
You can premiere it on the pod.
Yeah, but truly, yeah,
it must be hard to decide how to do that.
Yeah, I mean, I think that it's always fun to think of a different way to say a thing
and to, you know, to throw a metaphor in there.
There's got to be a way. And then look over there. I'll turn it to you first. You can premiere it on the pod. Yeah, but truly, yeah, it must be hard to decide how to do that. Yeah, I mean, I think that it's always fun to think of a different way to say a thing and to, you know, to throw a metaphor in there.
But also, you know, to just say the truth is so empowering.
Instead of like they're just sniffing each other, you know,
they take each other out on a date.
Oh my God.
It's the song's writing itself right now.
This is never going away.
Yeah, I mean, have you ever had, well, then conversely,
have you ever written a song and then had questions about it
But also, you know, to just say the truth is so empowering. Instead of like they're just sniffing each other, you know, they take each other out on a date. Oh my God. It's the song's writing itself right now. This is never going away. Yeah, I mean, have you ever had, well, then conversely, have you ever written a song and then had questions about it
or it felt like people misinterpreted it?
Like they think that it's about something.
You're like, oh, no, it's not about that.
That has happened a few times.
And then the other thing that happens is that,
You know, in the year 2026, there's only so many notes left.
There's only so many songs.
When we first started putting music out in the early 2000s,
or it felt like people misinterpreted it? Like they think that it's about something. You're like, oh, no, it's not about that. That has happened a few times. And then the other thing that happens is that, You know, in the year 2026, there's only so many notes left. There's only so many songs. When we first started putting music out in the early 2000s,
on any given Friday release day,
there would be anywhere from 30 to 50 new releases.
There are now thousands, 3 to 5,000 somewhere in their releases.
Oh, my God.
Every Friday.
I've known an unknown artist.
Yeah.
I mean, there's just.
on any given Friday release day, there would be anywhere from 30 to 50 new releases. There are now thousands, 3 to 5,000 somewhere in their releases. Oh, my God. Every Friday. I've known an unknown artist. Yeah. I mean, there's just.
so much music out there, which is both incredible.
And we love that there's so many people that are creative
and that there is new pathways for people to independently release music,
all these things.
But the landscape has just changed so much.
And so as writers, we have to adapt as well.
And musicians, you've got to find a new way to cut through.
And this is, it's 3,000 to 5,000 now.
so much music out there, which is both incredible. And we love that there's so many people that are creative and that there is new pathways for people to independently release music, all these things. But the landscape has just changed so much. And so as writers, we have to adapt as well. And musicians, you've got to find a new way to cut through. And this is, it's 3,000 to 5,000 now.
And then in a couple of years, you're going to have all the AI groups releasing stuff.
Exactly.
These labels, labels will probably just have certain groups that are fully AI, right?
How do you feel about that?
This one goes out to my mother.
Have you played around with, like, just get like a first draft of a song or, like, whether it's lyrics or melody, to see what AI can give you on just, just on just a first pass that you then would change to make your own?
I mean.
I mean, any kind of art, I think.
And then in a couple of years, you're going to have all the AI groups releasing stuff. Exactly. These labels, labels will probably just have certain groups that are fully AI, right? How do you feel about that? This one goes out to my mother. Have you played around with, like, just get like a first draft of a song or, like, whether it's lyrics or melody, to see what AI can give you on just, just on just a first pass that you then would change to make your own? I mean. I mean, any kind of art, I think.
think AI, I hear, can give you a first sort of pass at it as opposed to, because the hardest
thing is creating something out of nothing, right?
So about 25 years ago or whatever it was, 30-ish years ago, probably not that far back.
Let's call it 25.
I don't have the exact facts.
There's the introduction of auto-tune into the music-making process.
Tell Tracy what that is.
Before that, there were little tricks you could do to basically.
think AI, I hear, can give you a first sort of pass at it as opposed to, because the hardest thing is creating something out of nothing, right? So about 25 years ago or whatever it was, 30-ish years ago, probably not that far back. Let's call it 25. I don't have the exact facts. There's the introduction of auto-tune into the music-making process. Tell Tracy what that is. Before that, there were little tricks you could do to basically.
take the pitch of a singer
and just bring it slightly back in tune
so that it just sounded better.
And then there's compression,
which is another tool that's used.
So as modern music making,
much like film and TV,
started using the technology available to them,
take the pitch of a singer and just bring it slightly back in tune so that it just sounded better. And then there's compression, which is another tool that's used. So as modern music making, much like film and TV, started using the technology available to them,
it evolved, it changed,
and it became a part of the process
to where now,
hearing a song without auto tune
to your ear would,
probably sound odd or just slight pitch correction.
Rough.
Rough or unfinished or raw.
it evolved, it changed, and it became a part of the process to where now, hearing a song without auto tune to your ear would, probably sound odd or just slight pitch correction. Rough. Rough or unfinished or raw.
Or more real.
Or more real, exactly.
My thing as it relates to the AI conversation
and the creative process
is that it is inevitable that this thing that is available to everybody
will be used in some way
and there will both be good and bad examples of how it's used.
But I believe that the lived experience
Or more real. Or more real, exactly. My thing as it relates to the AI conversation and the creative process is that it is inevitable that this thing that is available to everybody will be used in some way and there will both be good and bad examples of how it's used. But I believe that the lived experience
the human experience cannot be replicated.
And certainly, you know,
songs about dogs sniffing each other's butts in the park
could only come from great minds, human minds.
Right.
But it's a really interesting conversation
because it's happening, you know,
the human experience cannot be replicated. And certainly, you know, songs about dogs sniffing each other's butts in the park could only come from great minds, human minds. Right. Right. But it's a really interesting conversation because it's happening, you know,
in the circles I run in L.A.
with other songwriters and, you know,
and screenwriters.
and it's it actually, and this isn't to like bring up the thing,
but I have this movie coming with Paul Rudd in June,
which is all about my character basically, effectively,
as artist, he's a sort of former pop star boy band artist
who is in a crossroads in his career,
in the circles I run in L.A. with other songwriters and, you know, and screenwriters. and it's it actually, and this isn't to like bring up the thing, but I have this movie coming with Paul Rudd in June, which is all about my character basically, effectively, as artist, he's a sort of former pop star boy band artist who is in a crossroads in his career,
who wants to go to that next level,
and he meets Paul in a happenstance situation
at a wedding that Paul's wedding band's playing at.
And basically,
I steal this song from him, and it becomes a global smash.
Oh, wow.
And he doesn't get the credit.
And then he comes after you?
who wants to go to that next level, and he meets Paul in a happenstance situation at a wedding that Paul's wedding band's playing at. And basically, I steal this song from him, and it becomes a global smash. Oh, wow. And he doesn't get the credit. And then he comes after you?
And he comes after me.
It's a really fun movie.
John Carney, the director, he's one of my favorite directors, and Paul's incredible in the movie.
But the basic kind of like hook of it is always had me when I first heard the logline,
and then when I read it, I was just blown away.
But it asks the same question, I feel like that some of the AI conversation asks,
Like, what is this idea of ownership of truth and accountability and all these things?
And, you know, I'm excited for people to see it because it will leave you with a lot of questions.
And he comes after me. It's a really fun movie. John Carney, the director, he's one of my favorite directors, and Paul's incredible in the movie. But the basic kind of like hook of it is always had me when I first heard the logline, and then when I read it, I was just blown away. But it asks the same question, I feel like that some of the AI conversation asks, Like, what is this idea of ownership of truth and accountability and all these things? And, you know, I'm excited for people to see it because it will leave you with a lot of questions.
Yeah.
I love that.
That sounds really good.
I think we all, they're all, everything around this topic or feel like just open-ended questions because we just don't know and we don't.
We're all trying so hard to figure out where it's going to end up.
And we're spending all our time just spitting our wheels going, what?
What's it going to be? Is it going to be good or bad? Is it going to be this or that?
Yeah. I love that. I love that. That sounds really good. I think we all, they're all, everything around this topic or feel like just open-ended questions because we just don't know and we don't. We're all trying so hard to figure out where it's going to end up. And we're spending all our time just spitting our wheels going, what? What's it going to be? Is it going to be good or bad? Is it going to be this or that?
And I guess we just, that's the frustrating part we have to kind of surrender to.
We don't know yet, you know?
Yeah.
What kind of, I'm curious, what kind of music do you listen to?
Like if you, if I were to turn on a playlist that you had right now, like what, what's the kind of stuff that,
and I'm sure it varies, like everybody, like you go through phases and stuff.
But do you have any kind of like specific genre or something that you always find yourself?
going back to
And I guess we just, that's the frustrating part we have to kind of surrender to. We don't know yet, you know? Yeah. What kind of, I'm curious, what kind of music do you listen to? Like if you, if I were to turn on a playlist that you had right now, like what, what's the kind of stuff that, and I'm sure it varies, like everybody, like you go through phases and stuff. But do you have any kind of like specific genre or something that you always find yourself? going back to
or artists that you really...
I have a few.
You know, I've got...
I make playlists that are themed.
So I'll do like a Nepo Baby's playlist.
And it's anyone that's related to...
That's funny.
Another famous musician.
or artists that you really... I have a few. You know, I've got... I make playlists that are themed. So I'll do like a Nepo Baby's playlist. And it's anyone that's related to... That's funny. Another famous musician.
And it starts a good debate of
who is the more famous musician of the two,
which is a fun one.
Or great songs with key changes.
So when me and my friends get together,
we sit down and have a couple drinks,
then we all like pass the phone around
and add to these playlists.
And it starts a good debate of who is the more famous musician of the two, which is a fun one. Or great songs with key changes. So when me and my friends get together, we sit down and have a couple drinks, then we all like pass the phone around and add to these playlists.
Oh, that's fun.
That's really cool.
Yeah, it's a fun game to play with your friends, if you ever want to do it.
And then outside of that, Django Reinhart is a gypsy jazz guitar player,
just really puts me at ease.
And it's always playing in our home along with, you know, my wife, Priyanka's is Indian.
And I've learned so much about the Bollywood film scene and Indian film as a whole
and the music from those movies and really come to love it.
Oh, that's fun. That's really cool. Yeah, it's a fun game to play with your friends, if you ever want to do it. And then outside of that, Django Reinhart is a gypsy jazz guitar player, just really puts me at ease. And it's always playing in our home along with, you know, my wife, Priyanka's is Indian. And I've learned so much about the Bollywood film scene and Indian film as a whole and the music from those movies and really come to love it.
So that's those, you know.
Those are kind of my tent pulls.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
This is such a hard one.
I don't know how I'd answer it.
Who's your favorite...
Do you have a favorite band of all time?
So that's those, you know. Those are kind of my tent pulls. We'll be right back. And back to the show. This is such a hard one. I don't know how I'd answer it. Who's your favorite... Do you have a favorite band of all time?
Yeah.
Favorite band of all the...
Oh, I know what yours is, Will.
What is it?
It's Built to Spill.
Built Spill is up there, but it's not number one.
Oh, is it...
What's the French...
Yeah. Favorite band of all the... Oh, I know what yours is, Will. What is it? It's Built to Spill. Built Spill is up there, but it's not number one. Oh, is it... What's the French...
The Smith.
The Frusian band.
Is it the Smith?
Smith is my number one band of all time.
I love that.
What about your French Fusion?
What's it called?
The Smith. The Frusian band. The Smith. Is it the Smith? Smith is my number one band of all time. I love that. What about your French Fusion? What's it called?
The French-Canadian fusion van
that you just go twat on and on about
No, he's not French-Cany.
Oh, Bonnie Bear.
Bonny Verre is not French Canadians.
He's from Wisconsin.
That's close.
It's close, and it's a French name.
The French-Canadian fusion van that you just go twat on and on about No, he's not French-Cany. Oh, Bonnie Bear. Bonny Verre is not French Canadians. He's from Wisconsin. That's close. It's close, and it's a French name.
Bonnie Bear is amazing, right?
Do you love Bonny Verre?
Oh, love.
Love. He's incredible.
Justin Vernon and those guys,
and he's just...
I think I turned you on to them, Will.
Sean Kerry.
Bonnie Bear is amazing, right? Do you love Bonny Verre? Oh, love. Love. He's incredible. Justin Vernon and those guys, and he's just... I think I turned you on to them, Will. Sean Kerry.
I mean, I was an early adopter.
Sean Kerry, who plays with
when Justin Vernon
when they were doing Bonavere,
Sean Kerry's got a beautiful voice,
and the two of them,
there's a version, if you want to...
It means good winter, so...
I mean, I was an early adopter. Sean Kerry, who plays with when Justin Vernon when they were doing Bonavere, Sean Kerry's got a beautiful voice, and the two of them, there's a version, if you want to... It means good winter, so...
It does, but without the age.
Just seeing you.
There's a song, they released,
they did it live in a studio,
and you can go look it on YouTube,
and it's Justin Vernon
and Sean Kerry on dueling pianos,
and they're doing bunny rates.
It does, but without the age. Just seeing you. There's a song, they released, they did it live in a studio, and you can go look it on YouTube, and it's Justin Vernon and Sean Kerry on dueling pianos, and they're doing bunny rates.
I can't make you love me.
It's one of the most incredible...
It's one of the most incredible performances.
J.B., make fun of it as much as you want.
You never understand it.
Okay?
You have the heart of AI
You have a heart of a...
I can't make you love me. It's one of the most incredible... It's one of the most incredible performances. J.B., make fun of it as much as you want. You never understand it. Okay? You have the heart of AI You have a heart of a...
I will not love it.
Jason has...
I would say, Jason has the personality of a Waymo driver.
But you...
Nick, I check it out.
Check it out.
Those guys doing...
I can't make you love me.
I will not love it. Jason has... I would say, Jason has the personality of a Waymo driver. But you... Nick, I check it out. Check it out. Those guys doing... I can't make you love me.
It's absolutely hard, but...
I want to know his answer.
I know.
What's your favorite band?
If you had to.
I mean, the Beatles, you know, of course.
Sure.
Okay.
It's absolutely hard, but... I want to know his answer. I know. What's your favorite band? If you had to. I mean, the Beatles, you know, of course. Sure. Okay.
And then the BeeGs.
I love the BeeGs.
There's a band called Switchfoot that we love.
They were really influential for us.
They had now called The Beautiful Letdown in 2003.
It's like San Diego.
I like that.
Just a rock kind of, it's that punk-pop, emo rock thing that we'd love.
And then the BeeGs. I love the BeeGs. There's a band called Switchfoot that we love. They were really influential for us. They had now called The Beautiful Letdown in 2003. It's like San Diego. I like that. Just a rock kind of, it's that punk-pop, emo rock thing that we'd love.
But yeah, the Beatles, I think, number one.
Sean, you got a favorite band?
Well, the Smiths is really, really, really, really high up there,
but probably Depeche Mode or Erasure or New Order.
All the European synth pop of the 80s and 90s.
I listen to it every day still.
Bronsky beat, erasure.
Yes, all those.
But yeah, the Beatles, I think, number one. Sean, you got a favorite band? Well, the Smiths is really, really, really, really high up there, but probably Depeche Mode or Erasure or New Order. All the European synth pop of the 80s and 90s. I listen to it every day still. Bronsky beat, erasure. Yes, all those.
What's the best concert you've ever seen?
Me?
Probably Depeche Mode.
Depeche Mode.
Yeah.
JB, best concert you've ever seen, J.B.
And favorite band.
Radiohead.
What's the best concert you've ever seen? Me? Probably Depeche Mode. Depeche Mode. Yeah. JB, best concert you've ever seen, J.B. And favorite band. Radiohead.
We know what it's Radiohead.
Yeah, yeah.
Radiohead, Radiohead.
Yeah.
I think the best concert I ever went to was like, I want to say, 85.
And it was the violent femmes and the Pogs and the Double Bill.
Wow, yeah.
Yeah, it was sick.
We know what it's Radiohead. Yeah, yeah. Radiohead, Radiohead. Yeah. I think the best concert I ever went to was like, I want to say, 85. And it was the violent femmes and the Pogs and the Double Bill. Wow, yeah. Yeah, it was sick.
Where'd they play?
In Toronto.
Toronto.
Yeah, I grew up in Toronto.
Great Concert City.
Is it a great concert city?
It is.
You know, one of the most asked questions on a golf course,
Where'd they play? In Toronto. Toronto. Yeah, I grew up in Toronto. Great Concert City. Is it a great concert city? It is. You know, one of the most asked questions on a golf course,
what I'm playing with some guys that I don't really know is always.
what's the best city to play in?
Yeah.
And it's, I, so it's Toronto.
Yes.
Mexico City.
Montreal, great concert city.
Great town.
what I'm playing with some guys that I don't really know is always. what's the best city to play in? Yeah. And it's, I, so it's Toronto. Yes. Mexico City. Montreal, great concert city. Great town.
Barcelona.
Wow.
And Brazil.
I mean, anywhere in Brazil.
Like, it's just, wow.
Listen, shout out to Toronto.
I just want to say to all my, all our Canadian listeners, we love you so much.
And our friends at RBC.
Barcelona. Wow. And Brazil. I mean, anywhere in Brazil. Like, it's just, wow. Listen, shout out to Toronto. I just want to say to all my, all our Canadian listeners, we love you so much. And our friends at RBC.
Wait a minute, but Nick.
Sorry, it's not a paid ad.
Not a paid ad.
Nick.
I'm from a little tiny town called Glen Allen, Illinois.
And you played at the village next day.
It's just a NetJet's trip away.
It's a NetJet's trip away.
Wait a minute, but Nick. Sorry, it's not a paid ad. Not a paid ad. Nick. I'm from a little tiny town called Glen Allen, Illinois. And you played at the village next day. It's just a NetJet's trip away. It's a NetJet's trip away.
Okay?
Net Jets, it's the easiest way to get around.
You know, but wait.
Did you guys go to the Masters this year?
Did not.
I went last year.
Yeah.
Were you there this year?
Okay? Net Jets, it's the easiest way to get around. You know, but wait. Did you guys go to the Masters this year? Did not. I went last year. Yeah. Were you there this year?
No, I missed it.
I'm up in Vancouver right now.
I'm speaking of Canada.
Is that right?
And I couldn't go.
But my brother, Joe, and I, we first went to the Masters back in 2017, 2016 or 17.
Whatever the Sergio Garcia year was, I think it was 17.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I missed it. I'm up in Vancouver right now. I'm speaking of Canada. Is that right? And I couldn't go. But my brother, Joe, and I, we first went to the Masters back in 2017, 2016 or 17. Whatever the Sergio Garcia year was, I think it was 17. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we kind of made a tradition of it.
We would go on Saturday night or Sunday morning and do Sunday.
Well, it's a tradition unlike any other.
And, you know, speaking of that, Jim Nance is he's kind of been a family
friend for a while. He's
come to a lot of shows with his daughter. They have
like a connection of coming to our shows together.
It's really sweet. And she's now
And then we kind of made a tradition of it. We would go on Saturday night or Sunday morning and do Sunday. Well, it's a tradition unlike any other. And, you know, speaking of that, Jim Nance is he's kind of been a family friend for a while. He's come to a lot of shows with his daughter. They have like a connection of coming to our shows together. It's really sweet. And she's now
married and
it's a beautiful thing. Anyway,
he let us come into Butler Cabin and
watch his intro a few
times. And
you know, I was there the year. Tiger
One, but I missed it this year.
And I think I've seen you
married and it's a beautiful thing. Anyway, he let us come into Butler Cabin and watch his intro a few times. And you know, I was there the year. Tiger One, but I missed it this year. And I think I've seen you
from afar at
Masters one of the years I went.
And just one quick golf story.
And sorry to bore you.
No.
I did this.
We're all in.
I did this commercial with Jordan Speath for AT&T.
from afar at Masters one of the years I went. And just one quick golf story. And sorry to bore you. No. I did this. We're all in. I did this commercial with Jordan Speath for AT&T.
AT&T, yes, yes.
And as a sweetener for the deal, they were like, hey, we're going to get you on to play on the Monday after the tournament.
Ooh, right after.
So I got to go and play Augusta.
How'd you score?
How'd you score in those conditions?
I'm not playing to it now, but at that point I was a seven.
Wow.
AT&T, yes, yes. And as a sweetener for the deal, they were like, hey, we're going to get you on to play on the Monday after the tournament. Ooh, right after. So I got to go and play Augusta. How'd you score? How'd you score in those conditions? I'm not playing to it now, but at that point I was a seven. Wow.
And the conditions were brutal.
But I shot at 84.
Very, that is really good.
Did you play their T's?
No, no, they had us up.
J.B., don't be, that's a dumb question.
Well, I mean, I don't know things.
I went and embarrassed myself.
And the conditions were brutal. But I shot at 84. Very, that is really good. Did you play their T's? No, no, they had us up. J.B., don't be, that's a dumb question. Well, I mean, I don't know things. I went and embarrassed myself.
I went with the Manning brothers about a year ago, just over a year ago,
and I really stunk up the joint.
I finally kind of got it together, but I really stuck up the joint.
But you got to see it.
I feel like they could actually be, like, real working actors.
No, the Manning brothers.
They're very funny.
Peyton Manning, he knows this.
I went with the Manning brothers about a year ago, just over a year ago, and I really stunk up the joint. I finally kind of got it together, but I really stuck up the joint. But you got to see it. I feel like they could actually be, like, real working actors. No, the Manning brothers. They're very funny. Peyton Manning, he knows this.
I've said, I've embarrassed him many times.
He's the greatest working athlete, former athlete actor of all time.
Yeah.
We're diehard Giants fans, so we had a couple of great years with Eli.
We love Eli, too.
We love Eli.
Legend.
Sean, you okay?
I've said, I've embarrassed him many times. He's the greatest working athlete, former athlete actor of all time. Yeah. We're diehard Giants fans, so we had a couple of great years with Eli. We love Eli, too. We love Eli. Legend. Sean, you okay?
Yeah.
Sean just tuned out more than ever.
He's still coming off his high from last night.
He had a campfire.
I don't know if you knew in Hancock Park, that little campfire.
Campfire for one?
I was going to ask you, because I was listening in before we jumped on,
how does that work?
Yeah. Sean just tuned out more than ever. He's still coming off his high from last night. He had a campfire. I don't know if you knew in Hancock Park, that little campfire. Campfire for one? I was going to ask you, because I was listening in before we jumped on, how does that work?
The campfire outside in California?
No, it's in the oven.
When I made my snore?
It's on the stove.
Oh, okay.
I was like, that seems really dangerous.
Or if the gas is shut off, he'll just go in the sauna, as we'll explain.
Yeah.
The campfire outside in California? No, it's in the oven. When I made my snore? It's on the stove. Oh, okay. I was like, that seems really dangerous. Or if the gas is shut off, he'll just go in the sauna, as we'll explain. Yeah.
So you'll just, you're just standing there jackassing it over
an open flame in your kitchen on the stove.
Yeah, absolutely.
And are you eating standing up?
Absolutely, standing up with a big glass of milk.
And then make the next one. That's right.
And your fingers are now sticky in.
Totally.
So you'll just, you're just standing there jackassing it over an open flame in your kitchen on the stove. Yeah, absolutely. And are you eating standing up? Absolutely, standing up with a big glass of milk. And then make the next one. That's right. And your fingers are now sticky in. Totally.
Well, wait, I'll bet you've got the phone.
I bet you're scrolling through your Instagram
while you're eating next to the stove.
No, I was listening to the Smiths, actually, last time.
Were you really?
Wait a second.
You're listening to the Smiths off your iPhone,
alone in your kitchen, making s'mores over your gas range.
Well, wait, I'll bet you've got the phone. I bet you're scrolling through your Instagram while you're eating next to the stove. No, I was listening to the Smiths, actually, last time. Were you really? Wait a second. You're listening to the Smiths off your iPhone, alone in your kitchen, making s'mores over your gas range.
That's right.
Fuck you.
And you're in slippers and like pills and flannels.
Totally.
It's just disgusting.
That's right. That's right. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. And you're in slippers and like pills and flannels. Totally. It's just disgusting.
Wait, Nick, we do have to get you.
You have to come play golf with this.
I don't know if you heard Jason's leaving,
so we can't play for a while.
Until August.
Have you guys had Kevin Hart on the podcast?
Yeah.
We have.
Wait, Nick, we do have to get you. You have to come play golf with this. I don't know if you heard Jason's leaving, so we can't play for a while. Until August. Have you guys had Kevin Hart on the podcast? Yeah. We have.
We have, yeah.
So he's, you know, newly obsessed with golf.
Is he?
Yeah.
I just finished up on the number three.
Jimonji, and he was literally scrolling, you know, just watching golf videos and practicing his swing with like this contraption.
It's like a thing that simulates like a golf, I don't know, it was very cool.
I find it on eBay.
We have, yeah. So he's, you know, newly obsessed with golf. Is he? Yeah. I just finished up on the number three. Jimonji, and he was literally scrolling, you know, just watching golf videos and practicing his swing with like this contraption. It's like a thing that simulates like a golf, I don't know, it was very cool. I find it on eBay.
Was this over in Hawaii?
Hawaii and some in L.A. as well.
And so in Hawaii, you played some yummy courses, I'll bet.
That's a yummy.
I didn't have a chance to.
I brought my daughter out with me.
and my parents, my wife is shooting in India,
so I brought her out.
Was this over in Hawaii? Hawaii and some in L.A. as well. And so in Hawaii, you played some yummy courses, I'll bet. That's a yummy. I didn't have a chance to. I brought my daughter out with me. and my parents, my wife is shooting in India, so I brought her out.
And I did the dad stuff.
We did like the dolphin swimming with the dolphins.
And I took her.
They're at the Kahala Hilton.
Yeah, I think so, yeah.
And they have a Disney hotel.
And so, you know, she went and met Moana and all.
It was great.
And I did the dad stuff. We did like the dolphin swimming with the dolphins. And I took her. They're at the Kahala Hilton. Yeah, I think so, yeah. And they have a Disney hotel. And so, you know, she went and met Moana and all. It was great.
I sacrificed the golf for the dad.
Talk to me about India.
How is India?
Yeah.
I've never been there.
I haven't been there.
I'm desperate to go.
I'm so desperate to go.
I sacrificed the golf for the dad. Talk to me about India. How is India? Yeah. I've never been there. I haven't been there. I'm desperate to go. I'm so desperate to go.
You should bring the podcast there and do it.
We should do that.
That's a great idea.
Smartless goes to India.
I watch a little bit of Indian, this is true, Indian Premier League cricket from time to time.
Oh, yeah.
And there's this new kid he plays.
I forget what I'm, yeah, the IPL.
You should bring the podcast there and do it. We should do that. That's a great idea. Smartless goes to India. I watch a little bit of Indian, this is true, Indian Premier League cricket from time to time. Oh, yeah. And there's this new kid he plays. I forget what I'm, yeah, the IPL.
This kid, he's 15.
He's like this tonal.
The Indian team?
He plays for one of the teams.
No, I don't know if he's playing for the national team.
He's playing for one of the teams in the IPL right now.
This kid is having...
I actually watched the game where he was out after one run,
This kid, he's 15. He's like this tonal. The Indian team? He plays for one of the teams. No, I don't know if he's playing for the national team. He's playing for one of the teams in the IPL right now. This kid is having... I actually watched the game where he was out after one run,
but this kid is like an absolute sensation.
He's 15 and everybody else is way old.
Yeah, he's sensational.
I love cricket.
Do you think the audience is hanging on
to this particular section
about the Indian Cricket League?
I don't know.
but this kid is like an absolute sensation. He's 15 and everybody else is way old. Yeah, he's sensational. I love cricket. Do you think the audience is hanging on to this particular section about the Indian Cricket League? I don't know.
You think they're fucking...
In India, they are.
Let me tell you something.
In India, the whole audience, something.
He gets that.
Jason just straightened himself.
Well, yeah.
You should go to India.
You think they're fucking... In India, they are. Let me tell you something. In India, the whole audience, something. He gets that. Jason just straightened himself. Well, yeah. You should go to India.
So Priyanka's been shooting there, this movie by the director of it did RRR.
It was his last film.
Oh, sure, sure, sure.
Yeah, that got a lot of great notice.
Yeah, a big Indian kind of epic film,
and she's not done a movie there in about eight years.
So it's a big deal, her return.
You know, she did 80-something movies before she started doing movies.
So Priyanka's been shooting there, this movie by the director of it did RRR. It was his last film. Oh, sure, sure, sure. Yeah, that got a lot of great notice. Yeah, a big Indian kind of epic film, and she's not done a movie there in about eight years. So it's a big deal, her return. You know, she did 80-something movies before she started doing movies.
That's crazy.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Over 80 films?
Over 80 films, yeah.
She's 75 years old, Will.
That's crazy. Wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait. Over 80 films? Over 80 films, yeah. She's 75 years old, Will.
It's a fascinating thing, though.
The way in which the Indian audience reveres their film talent, their stars, is, it's like unlike anything I've ever seen before.
And it's obviously an enormous audience, you know, over a billion people in India.
And then globally, the reach is so big.
And there's a bunch of projects that are really started to make a huge.
impact globally now as well, which is exciting to see.
The culture there, I hear that weddings are a major thing.
Did you guys have a bit of an Indian wedding or no?
It's a fascinating thing, though. The way in which the Indian audience reveres their film talent, their stars, is, it's like unlike anything I've ever seen before. And it's obviously an enormous audience, you know, over a billion people in India. And then globally, the reach is so big. And there's a bunch of projects that are really started to make a huge. impact globally now as well, which is exciting to see. The culture there, I hear that weddings are a major thing. Did you guys have a bit of an Indian wedding or no?
We did.
So we were friends for about a year before we started dating.
And then once we started dating, it all happened very fast.
We just both just kind of knew.
So, you know, first real date was in.
May, and then by July we were engaged, and married in December the same year.
Wow. That's awesome. How did you guys meet?
We had a mutual friend who kept saying, you know, you guys will really hit it off.
We did. So we were friends for about a year before we started dating. And then once we started dating, it all happened very fast. We just both just kind of knew. So, you know, first real date was in. May, and then by July we were engaged, and married in December the same year. Wow. That's awesome. How did you guys meet? We had a mutual friend who kept saying, you know, you guys will really hit it off.
I'm going to connect you, and he never did, and I got frustrated waiting, and I saw a billboard
of her on Sunset Boulevard for her show Quantico. I was like, you know what, fuck it. I'm going
to see if she follows me on Twitter, and she did.
Wow. Wow. Wow. And so I messaged her, and we went back and forth for a bit. We met for a
drink just kind of casually in New York. And it took, you know, a year or a year and a half for us to
really say, all right, let's separate the time in our schedules to just like give this a go,
go on a date and see what happens. So we did and it was literally, you know, instant. And we both
just kind of knew. So flash forward to the wedding, we decided to do it in India. And we were scrambling
I'm going to connect you, and he never did, and I got frustrated waiting, and I saw a billboard of her on Sunset Boulevard for her show Quantico. I was like, you know what, fuck it. I'm going to see if she follows me on Twitter, and she did. Wow. Wow. Wow. And so I messaged her, and we went back and forth for a bit. We met for a drink just kind of casually in New York. And it took, you know, a year or a year and a half for us to really say, all right, let's separate the time in our schedules to just like give this a go, go on a date and see what happens. So we did and it was literally, you know, instant. And we both just kind of knew. So flash forward to the wedding, we decided to do it in India. And we were scrambling
to find a place to do it because we had spoken to
Priyanka's mother's pundit,
her spiritual guide and astrologer,
and they had said that the best window,
the most auspicious window would be in December.
So we're like, all right, we've got to find a wedding venue.
And she showed me this video of this commercial
that she had shot at this place, this palace in India.
to find a place to do it because we had spoken to Priyanka's mother's pundit, her spiritual guide and astrologer, and they had said that the best window, the most auspicious window would be in December. So we're like, all right, we've got to find a wedding venue. And she showed me this video of this commercial that she had shot at this place, this palace in India.
And she was like,
there's no way this would ever be available.
when I shot here 10 years ago, I said I want to get married there someday.
And so her friend who was with us, her best friend and her best friend's husband,
he was like, let me just cold call them right now and see if they're available for these dates.
And he stepped out of the room and he came back about 10 minutes later.
He goes, they're available.
It's the one weekend this entire year that they have available for a wedding.
And she was like, there's no way this would ever be available. when I shot here 10 years ago, I said I want to get married there someday. And so her friend who was with us, her best friend and her best friend's husband, he was like, let me just cold call them right now and see if they're available for these dates. And he stepped out of the room and he came back about 10 minutes later. He goes, they're available. It's the one weekend this entire year that they have available for a wedding.
Wow.
How crazy is that?
So we did what's called a Sengit ceremony, which is the first night.
Basically, it's a really fun.
tradition where the families, the whole thing is about not just the couple, but introducing
the families and integrating them together. And there's the spirit of competition that comes
along with Indian weddings. So you basically do a performance and you battle and the family
that wins the performance is the more dominant family. So on her side, you have like her
Wow. How crazy is that? So we did what's called a Sengit ceremony, which is the first night. Basically, it's a really fun. tradition where the families, the whole thing is about not just the couple, but introducing the families and integrating them together. And there's the spirit of competition that comes along with Indian weddings. So you basically do a performance and you battle and the family that wins the performance is the more dominant family. So on her side, you have like her
global Bollywood icon and Hollywood star along with a bunch of her cousins and other folks
and her family who are also Indian film stars.
And then on our side, you've got the motherfucking Jonas brothers.
Hello.
And our friends and family.
And it was epic.
It's like a song competition, dance competition, both?
Like a show.
global Bollywood icon and Hollywood star along with a bunch of her cousins and other folks and her family who are also Indian film stars. And then on our side, you've got the motherfucking Jonas brothers. Hello. And our friends and family. And it was epic. It's like a song competition, dance competition, both? Like a show.
I'm not even kidding you.
It was like a 45-minute show.
Come on.
Wow.
She crushed it.
Her side crushed it.
And then we came out and I walked out
because they did what the actors do in Indian cinema,
I'm not even kidding you. It was like a 45-minute show. Come on. Wow. She crushed it. Her side crushed it. And then we came out and I walked out because they did what the actors do in Indian cinema,
which is that there's a playback singer, it's called,
or an artist,
but then the actors on screen,
in character, lip sync to the song.
Right, right, although it's a different singer.
So they did that, and I walked out and got on the mic and said,
you know, we have one thing, you know,
it was an amazing performance, and you all crushed it,
which is that there's a playback singer, it's called, or an artist, but then the actors on screen, in character, lip sync to the song. Right, right, although it's a different singer. So they did that, and I walked out and got on the mic and said, you know, we have one thing, you know, it was an amazing performance, and you all crushed it,
and we're humbled and honored to get to go after you,
but we have one thing that you don't.
Live microphones, and then we start out.
Is there a strategy to going first or second?
Did you guys flip a coin to see who would start?
We didn't flip a coin.
It just kind of happened that way, and I'm glad it did because, you know,
it put the fear of God in all my friends and family
and we're humbled and honored to get to go after you, but we have one thing that you don't. Live microphones, and then we start out. Is there a strategy to going first or second? Did you guys flip a coin to see who would start? We didn't flip a coin. It just kind of happened that way, and I'm glad it did because, you know, it put the fear of God in all my friends and family
when we were backstage after and it was like,
we got a whole fucking line.
They brought it.
Like, now is the time.
I've never needed you more.
And so we did that.
Then basically we did a Western Christian wedding.
and then the following day was the Indian ceremony.
when we were backstage after and it was like, we got a whole fucking line. They brought it. Like, now is the time. I've never needed you more. And so we did that. Then basically we did a Western Christian wedding. and then the following day was the Indian ceremony.
So three nights.
And by the way, that's a short, considered a short Indian wedding.
Usually they can go up to, you know, a week or two.
I was just thinking, I was imagining if we introduced that here in America,
sort of the competition element to a wedding.
And I was just thinking of like a wedding up in Massachusetts of two families.
I'm like, fuck you.
Yeah, you motherfucker.
So three nights. And by the way, that's a short, considered a short Indian wedding. Usually they can go up to, you know, a week or two. I was just thinking, I was imagining if we introduced that here in America, sort of the competition element to a wedding. And I was just thinking of like a wedding up in Massachusetts of two families. I'm like, fuck you. Yeah, you motherfucker.
You thought that was trash.
Now it's maybe we're fucking immediately like,
yeah, we go, let's kill these clowns fucking, you know.
Total brawl.
It escalate quickly.
Yeah, wow, that's so cool.
Dude, that is really cool.
I can't believe it's already been an hour.
You thought that was trash. Now it's maybe we're fucking immediately like, yeah, we go, let's kill these clowns fucking, you know. Total brawl. It escalate quickly. Yeah, wow, that's so cool. Dude, that is really cool. I can't believe it's already been an hour.
Yeah, we didn't get to much.
I know.
But so much.
It's a good, it's always a good sign when you just roll through.
Nick, man, you're such a talent, dude.
You're such a great dude.
And just love what you do and so much admiration for all of it.
And just continued success.
Yeah, we didn't get to much. I know. But so much. It's a good, it's always a good sign when you just roll through. Nick, man, you're such a talent, dude. You're such a great dude. And just love what you do and so much admiration for all of it. And just continued success.
Thanks for making time where you're there at work.
right? You're in your trailer there. Thank you for doing this now.
Of course. And I'd love to come back next time with the bros too.
Yeah, come on. We'd love that. We'd love that. That would be dope.
We've got to play some golf, you know? We've got to get it all done.
Yeah, let's get it all done. Thanks for having you guys. This was awesome.
Thank you, Nick. We can just.
Okay, you know what? That's it for Nick. Okay. Jason, we're good. Okay. Somebody cut off Jason's Mike.
Thanks for making time where you're there at work. right? You're in your trailer there. Thank you for doing this now. Of course. And I'd love to come back next time with the bros too. Yeah, come on. We'd love that. We'd love that. That would be dope. We've got to play some golf, you know? We've got to get it all done. Yeah, let's get it all done. Thanks for having you guys. This was awesome. Thank you, Nick. We can just. Okay, you know what? That's it for Nick. Okay. Jason, we're good. Okay. Somebody cut off Jason's Mike.
Thank you, Nick. Thanks, Nick. Thanks, nice to see you again.
All right, pal. Good to see you later. Bye.
Nick Jonas.
That is Nick Jonas.
Yeah.
You're an impressive dude.
Oh, yeah.
When I saw him backstage with Golden Gloves
Thank you, Nick. Thanks, Nick. Thanks, nice to see you again. All right, pal. Good to see you later. Bye. Nick Jonas. That is Nick Jonas. Yeah. You're an impressive dude. Oh, yeah. When I saw him backstage with Golden Gloves
with Priyanka, it was just us
three.
We were chatting for like,
you know, like a half an hour.
It was great.
It was so cool.
Do you think they rolled their eyes
after they walked away from you?
with Priyanka, it was just us three. We were chatting for like, you know, like a half an hour. It was great. It was so cool. Do you think they rolled their eyes after they walked away from you?
Yeah, absolutely.
Who the fuck is that?
Why is that guy talking to us?
This guy is...
Why they let such random people
backstage?
I don't care.
Cooking s'mores.
Yeah, absolutely. Who the fuck is that? Why is that guy talking to us? This guy is... Why they let such random people backstage? I don't care. Cooking s'mores.
He's wearing scers to an award show.
It's wearing, could you
By the way, that sounds like a dream.
But it's very admirable that he is, you know,
just thriving and incredibly relevant
and working like a dog.
And, you know, he's made that transition
from Child Star to adult.
He's wearing scers to an award show. It's wearing, could you By the way, that sounds like a dream. But it's very admirable that he is, you know, just thriving and incredibly relevant and working like a dog. And, you know, he's made that transition from Child Star to adult.
Yeah, I mean, and started on Broadway.
I didn't even mention that.
He and I years ago went to a hospital here in Los Angeles
around the holidays and visiting with all these kids were sick.
And he brought his guitar and he played some,
for all these kids individually.
And it was so, yeah, it was so moving.
I mean, it's like...
Yeah, I mean, and started on Broadway. I didn't even mention that. He and I years ago went to a hospital here in Los Angeles around the holidays and visiting with all these kids were sick. And he brought his guitar and he played some, for all these kids individually. And it was so, yeah, it was so moving. I mean, it's like...
Like, he was just giving, he was so generous.
Yeah, and doesn't stop with his time like that.
Like that, or, or, I mean, going from movie to concert,
to the recording studio to the, like, it's exhausting.
Sounds exhausting.
Oh, oh.
Oh, that was it.
I thought that was a leading to a bottom.
Like, he was just giving, he was so generous. Yeah, and doesn't stop with his time like that. Like that, or, or, I mean, going from movie to concert, to the recording studio to the, like, it's exhausting. Sounds exhausting. Oh, oh. Oh, that was it. I thought that was a leading to a bottom.
No, we were both thought you were leading into it.
No, but they do have, they do have a, you know, a, you know,
a song, a title called Goodbye, it's an album or a song or something.
Yeah.
So we got to give you a quick lesson on how to do the bye thing.
Well, there's a song called LoveBod.
I will say that his, you know, he, like, he's got the music and the acting and all this stuff.
And so, like, how does he decide how he's going to, with his career, how he's going to go, like,
不，我们都以为你要引入这个话题了。不，不过他们确实有，他们确实有，你知道的，有一首，你知道的，一首歌，一首叫《再见》的歌，这是一张专辑还是一首歌什么的。对。所以我们得给你快速上一课，教你该怎么说再见。好吧，有一首歌叫《LoveBod》。我要说的是，他的，你知道的，他，比如，他既有音乐又有表演还有诸如此类的东西。所以，比如，他该如何决定他的职业生涯，他将如何发展，比如，
to buy for Kate.
Those two talents.
Bye for Kate.
This got to be the worst part of every episode.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by
Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico,
为凯特买。这两种才华。凯特再见。这肯定是每集节目中最糟糕的部分。《Smartless》。《Smartless》由罗布·阿尔姆贾夫、贝内特·巴比科百分之百有机且经手工匠心制作，
and Michael Grant Terry.
Smartless.
以及迈克尔·格兰特·特里。《Smartless》。